good morning
i'm david warr and uh i want to thank
the organizers of emerging languages and
strangers for giving us
that one day out of the year or even our
fellow
engineering colleagues let's get to be
the language nerds who really are
you know but it's not a little time it's
not already placed this is the place to
kind of enjoy ourselves
so uh in addition also my family
who allows me to come here and spend my
free time hacking on languages
so why the first question everyone asks
and no language designer wants to hear
it is why did you do this what problem
are you trying to solve
what's wrong with closure what probably
can assault there
um i think we all know the first reason
any language gets put together is an
itch the author wants to scratch in my
case there are two issues i want to
scratch one i want to explore
the concatenative stack-based paradigm
the language that approach
to expressing code and secondly i wanted
to get a deeper understanding of closure
and
you know we're at the emerging languages
camp and um do i think gershwin
is an emerging language not necessarily
but i think closure
is an emerging language and culture is
more than an emerging language the
interesting part of gershwin
is that as an extension of closure so
gershwin is an experiment as an
extension to closure
to provide to make a closure that is
stack missing cabinet
so it raises certain questions that i
think are worth exploration um
what makes a language extension worthy
how would i bother explaining closure
closer to the language why would i want
closure as my basis um
and then how far can we take it until
we've broken what it means to be
a language i don't think gershwin breaks
closure
but she'll be the end of the talk
so um to kind of evaluate a language
design and talk about how
it's extensible i think it's it's
profitable to
kind of compare how we study human
foreign languages to how we
grapple with programming languages and
so
i kind of want to take these two in
stride and kind of compare and contrast
and we'll explore a little bit of
closure and gross implementation along
the way
so the first thing that we study is
humans when studying a foreign language
is usually pronunciation you got to
spend some time
training the muscles of your mouth and
your throat to pronounce things
correctly
kind of the parallel and programming
might be the syntax of the language
so human languages right are
it doesn't matter what language you
speak or what language you're learning
you're probably doing r
wrong when you're learning that foreign
language right whether it's a front
rolled r whether it's a
back rolled r whether it's maybe an r
maybe an l sound is not much distinction
or in english where it's not really even
a consonant is more of a semi-vowel
right um this is a hard problem we all
have opinions
um you know r is just it's a tough one
um
programming parallel super quick closure
recap
of what's available in closure string
literals keywords or symbols depending
on your background i'm kind of assuming
folks are relatively familiar with
closure
for those watching this video online i
suggest spending time reading some other
tutorials and watching some videos
we have uh symbols numbers proper ratios
regular expressions
and then some closure specific things
like uh reader macros for closure vars
so moving along
lisp essentials how you call things in
lisps what you're calling in a list
functions macros official forms
and then uh some of the collections that
closure has some syntax for
to include vectors hash maps and sets so
this is all the closure primer we get
today
i kind of assume that folks are
relatively familiar with with closure
and we'll see enough along the way that
i hope folks can absorb if not
so what does gershwin add so i said
gershwin is an extension to closure
it's an additive extension the gershwin
the grocery jar
uh can compile any closure program that
one six master can
compile but there's some things that it
adds to what's available
um because it's a stack based encontent
of language there are no there's no
specific
call or invocation syntax and we'll see
what that means we look at some code
examples and there's no parens
to call functions that seems kind of
counterintuitive that a lisp
loses its parens well they're still
there
they have a different purpose um
functions aren't called functions and
and kind of languages usually called
words so we get the vocabulary right
here functions are called words
and we use in the fourth tradition a
colon to define words
and we also have anonymous functions
those are called quotations
and we use uh this syntax which is
another reader macro
for writing quotations these are the two
kind of major additions
that gershwin brings to closure a way to
talk about functions as words because
they're going to behave differently than
regular functions
and a way to have code that will get
executed at some later point but don't
execute it right now and that's
quotations
are somewhat parallel to anonymous
functions
the last little tidbit of information
that's an addition is that gershwin
words and closure functions can show the
same names in the same name space
because they behave differently
and i provide one extra bit of syntax to
distinguish when you're talking about a
gershwin word versus a closure
function so that's all that
gershwin adds to closure and we're going
to see there's quite a bit that that
brings to the language
that brings to being able to program
closure in a concatenative style
i'm improper programming tutorial style
i'm not going to jump from assuming you
didn't even know closure syntax to
assuming you know the closure compiler
and that these things make sense
um but for those who are familiar with
closure and its compiler this will make
a lot of sense these are simple editions
so
lisp reader is closure's
basic reader or parser closure doesn't
allow adding
reader macros and rigor closure you
can't add any extra special symbols that
don't look like s expressions or the or
the syntax that's been defined
unless you hack the compiler which it
did uh so
we have these two reader macros is it
before that first one is for quotations
the equivalent of anonymous functions
and the second one is that special
gershwin var distinction
and the second is that i extended the
reader to also be able to parse colons
as the beginning of a word definition in
addition to this
existing usage enclosure which is for
keywords as we saw before
the only other bookkeeping change that
had to happen was i had to increase the
pushback reader buffer to be able to
distinguish between colon plus a space
for a word definition and colon and uh
an identifier for a keyword so
that's the basics we can pronounce our
r's correctly or incorrectly more than
likely
and we've mastered the syntax of closure
and we've seen what little things are
from that gershwin adds to closure
next thing up words and phrases build
the basic vocabulary
how do you make sense what what's the
beginning of the semantics of the given
human language
and the equivalent i would say is the
primitives of the language you're
dealing with in terms of computer
programming
um in this case functions or objects and
methods um
so this is the second stage of our
closure primer where i assume you're
just gonna
now know how to work in lisp um
plus function with arguments of 2 and 2
gives us 4.
if i have a hash map with an entry foo
bar and i ask for the phu key i get that
closure takes things a bit further than
a lot of functional programming
languages
its collections can also act like
functions and it makes sense and so a
map
can be used as a function for retrieving
things out of it so if i
invoke that map as a function and pass
it the foo
keyword as a key as an argument it will
return the value at that key and vice
versa keywords are also
also invokables and i can do the same
thing so those last three code snippets
are equivalent in closure
and i think it's profitable to realize
that
not everything you think is a function
is a function and things you think
shouldn't be functions or often
functions
we have high order functions it's a
functional language i can apply
in this case the hashmap constructor if
you will and get a hashmap from
items in a collection pairwise and
finally the traditional map
where map takes a function and a
collection and maps the function over
the collection determining a collection
that is
the return values of invoking that
function for each item in the list
all right one step further those are all
uh built-in closure functions how do we
define our own
like and how we can have some data so
def is kind of that central form for
defining
named things enclosure and then
definition macro on top of that that
lets us define functions easily so
here's a simple example of having some
some standalone data um and then two
functions
a very simple function of times two
given an argument x multiply it by two
we take it a step further we can have a
generic times in function that
itself returns a function that
multiplies a given number by
the uh the n that you supplied so how
would we use this
again just trying to show off the the
closure functional aspect
um times n2 or within a function that
times anything by two
and give that four and you get eight and
again another another way of showing it
to map a function
times into over a collection again
another way i find that it helps when
looking the functional language is to
take
uh different perspectives on what where
functions can be put and what things
expect functions and what things invoke
functions there's just a couple of
examples in closure
all right so given those examples in
enclosure i would write them in a stack
based language
these are the gershwin examples that are
parallel put two on the stack
put two on the stack put the plus word
on the stack
and the plus will look on the stack grab
its arguments and put the return value
back on the stack that's four
the same map getting we saw before i can
take
a map and the keyword and get the value
out of it
i can use a map like a function
i can use a keyword like a function so
in this case gershwin has taken the word
apply
and change what it means from default
closure to say
take the thing on the top of the stack
treat it like a word
and give it arguments off the rest of
the stack
this is in concatenative stack based
languages
there is generally not variable arity so
you tend to have a lot of functions that
have specific areas in the name like you
know foo one food two food three if it
takes multiple items
in this case kind of taking a little bit
of a ruby convention and
for functions that need to take a
collection and apply a function over
that collection to build them
this is the equivalent of that closure
apply hash map to that collection to
build a hash map from a variable number
of items and a vector
and finally the same map we saw before
this takes
map instead of taking a function takes a
quotation which we said was the
equivalent of an anonymous function
and for each item in that collection one
two three four
it'll put each item on the stack and
then invoke the quotation with that item
on the stack
a little bit different terms of the
semantics of what we said before
foreclosure is not applying a function
across a collection it's
working with the stack applying invoking
quotations
along the way so that's kind of hard
um let's look at how we define where our
own functions
so most concatenative languages
don't have variables by default it's
point free
programming where you don't have named
variables but they're useful
and even things like the factor
programming language we'll talk about
later
includes a way to have variables i could
make up a syntax for variables but
closure already has an excellent
facility for
naming things that just need to be in
this case stateful so this is an atom
and the second line is the function
definition or the word definition for
gershwin
um times two the the second thing you
see there may look like
a set of parameters but it's not it's a
stack effect
so uh due diligence in most
concatenative languages stack-based
languages is to show
what your word should do to the stack
some languages like factor even
programmatically verify
that if you say that these 10 words when
used in combination should have this
net stack effect it checks it does an
analysis of your code to make sure that
you actually have the stack effect in
place
and throws a compiler error if you don't
a to do on the gershwin list
so how would i use that if i put four on
the stack and invoke the word times two
i get eight
and you'll notice i didn't include the
times n equivalent here because
at this point you know how how would you
make a times n
word times n word would just be
the multiplication word um because
there's no
explicit querying it's what i find on
the stack if it's not
a word i'll put it on the stack if it is
a word i'll invoke it
right looking at the map equivalent here
i can map
times two across that or i can just
replace that
two times with my times two word above
you'll note
this is one of those the selling points
for competitive languages one of the
reasons that i wanted to explore it
there was no to refactor the third code
sample down all we had to do was take
two
and the multiplication word copy and
paste them out into a times two word and
put that word in its place
there's no explicit arguments passed in
there's no formal parameters
in the word definition so to refactor a
given
concatenated program you can copy and
paste at arbitrary points in your code
flow
name them words and put the words in
their place
obviously that adds mental overhead in
terms of thinking about the stack and
what the effect is but
it also allows you to factor very
seamlessly
okay so usually it's just backwards
right
you just take what closure took map and
a function in a collection
and gershwin takes the opposite it takes
the collection then the quotation
then map so let's look at it i think it
helps to look at this kind of you know
in motion this is our this is our
chopsticks composition
start with map what's the next thing map
takes it takes a function or a quotation
what's the next thing it takes
a collection if we start reading from
the word or the function in question
it's usually in reverse
that's not too bad let's try one that's
multi-line let's try a harder one
okay so so associate closures way of
saying given an associated data
structure
i'm going to give you a key and a value
please add the key to the map and give
it the value
so i'm going to search i start with a
map
i give it a key i give it a value and i
get
a new a new map with that entry added
okay again it's just in reverse not too
bad not too bad
wait a minute wait a minute
uh-oh did i mess up
that was an order that one's the same
okay
all right so if there's a couple things
going on here right so the closure
version
if is a uh if is a macro takes three
forms right takes a condition
a then branch in an else branch um so
the condition is if the answer is 42.
everything's okay in the universe if not
something's gone wrong um what's going
on in the gershwin version
so we read from left to right top to
bottom like we do um
answer is some bit of data it should
equal 42
and the equals equals word we'll put
we'll take those two arguments answer in
42 and say to these equal if they do
i'll put a boolean on the stack
and say yes they do um so now i have a
boolean
and then two quotations a boolean then
okay else bad and then finally a proper
concatenate of
fashion the word is at the end um
why is it that way i think for
several things we think about you know
when we reason about conditions for
example
there's a human tendency to think of if
then else
and it's hard um you know it's hard to
rethink some of those
those those orders and so for certain
things like if for certain things like
some mathematical operations i've taken
my cue from the factor programming
language
it goes in reverse reverse order or in
normal order
so if then else
uh the other thing to note about this is
that um why did we wrap the then and the
else branches in quotations
um if it's just a word and one of those
other selling points that get you really
excited about
stack based languages you're looking at
old fourth posts and some of those
fourth posts
show the beginning of a fourth
implementation is
defining the comment word and it says
now we have
comments in our code and so you've
defined how to have comments at the very
beginning and you can use comments from
then forward
the word is this kind of atomic
function-like
mechanism that has supreme power over a
stack-based language
in this case if it's just a regular word
that takes two quotations and a
quotation
delays evaluation until you call it to
invoke it so
instead of having if be a special form
or a macro in this case just a regular
word that takes quotations and those
quotations get invoked
based on the boolean all right
yeah it's we're not happy right reverse
and reverse
but some things just read both ways
right even in arabic you read words
right to left but numbers read
left to right that's 2009. right so
there's a precedent even in human
languages
the other part of learning words and
phrases in a human language and learning
programming languages is sometimes you
don't really learn what they mean when
you learn them
right when you first stay a french class
going to they don't
talk about you know what person and
number ale
is but russian for you know bless you to
a friend
you're not talking about the fact that
boot is an imperative and that's a short
from adjective
you just learn as bless you and you say
it you know like that and
in arabic hi it doesn't just mean hi
right but there's more there but we
learn these phrases as human beings as
learners we learn them in phrase chunks
because they're meaningful in those
chunks
and later on we'll learn the component
parts the same thing happens for
programming languages as we well know
copy and paste code oh this does this
magic method does this thing i'll copy
and paste it
closure is relatively devoid of such
things in my opinion
in my experience things generally look
you know have a reasonable core function
and
kind of work the way you expect one of
my hiccups
when learning closure was how do you ask
whether or not a vector has an item in
it
as the beginning learner you find the
contains function you're like oh yes
it's the contains function it's going to
be the contains function no it's not the
contains function
the contains function has a purpose it
uses associated data structures and says
does this associate associated structure
have the key i'm interested in
um so you ask around and you finally
find there's an idiom for this
it's a little tough at first right so we
harken back to the fact that sets
like other collections can be functions
and sum takes a function a predicate
and takes each item off the the other
collection
and the first item that has is truthy
it'll return that value out of the list
and that value will be truthy so this is
a way of finding of of saying whether or
not a vector has an item
but in general i want to argue that
closure is relatively devoid of of
these hardships all right so we just
looked at how grocery gets executed what
did i have to change to the compiler to
make this work
we added words we added quotations that
was it what happens in the compiler
um gershwin as i said can compile
closure code so if you just use a
gershwin
grisham jar like you would use a closure
jar you won't know any different
but if you decide to use the entry
points defined by gershwin then you'll
get some gershwin
extra handling so gershwin main parallel
to closure main
provides an entry point for starting a
grisham rebel and for loading files
the difference in the rebel is mainly
that it prints the stack instead of
printing return values from
things being invoked the compiler itself
again additive changes so the main kind
of the main
load function the compilers compiler
load the other ones load file et cetera
but load is the main one it takes one
extra argument which says am i in
gershwin world or am i not
and that's it if you're not in griswold
world it's just closure if you're
ingrossian world it's gershwin
um i said there's no parentheses in
gershwin i lied there is it's for
closure enron whenever grisham meets the
parenthesis it says okay i give up
it's closure so you can have things like
def my data in the middle of your code
because you need to you need a variable
and you don't want to you want to don't
want to work around the fact that a
concatenative language
shouldn't have variables
all right so when we're evaluating
gershwin code there's only two things
that gershwin cares about
if it's a word if it's not a word just
put it on the stack if it's a value
it's a number if it's a literal if it's
a regex if it's whatever it is if it's a
word
i want to invoke it when it's met this
is just closure function turtles all the
way down
in the compiler so if you look at the
closure compiler you'll see
very clean delineation for how each
form of the language is evaluated and
then you look at the asm byteco
generation you're like thank you rich
for doing that for me
um and so i we're not going to reinvent
functions they're already there so in
the compiler gershwin
transforms regular regular uh values and
words into function invocations that
either put things on the stack or invoke
words that do things to the stack
so we've talked about this stack it's
this ominous beast hanging in the
background the whole time
you have to keep this stack in your head
how is it implemented
it implements eye persistent stack which
is a an interface provided by closure it
gives us free access from closure to say
things like peak and pop
off of our stack um under the under the
covers it's
written as a java file but on the covers
is just using closure vectors
and gershwin stores that as a var in the
grisham core namespace which allows us
to
rebind the stack so for example if i
want to do things like pmap and i want
to have a clean stack per thread
and not worry about any kind of clashes
over a shared stack out in the ether
i can just have my own local stacks and
not worry about the fact that
it might clash so that's stored as a
dynamic var
and grisham core all right so all that
being said you've seen a couple of small
mini examples of stack based of gershwin
which is
kind of inspired from fourth and from
factor um how can we describe what the
stack based approach is why would you
care of saying these why would you go
further or would you study
stack based languages what would compel
you to i'm going to steal michael focus
in all of his descriptive power from the
next few slides
um he you know in his perlis languages
blog post he goes through and the first
one he picks is joy which is another
stack based component of language
and his submit has some you know
succinct things to say about how it
works
as we saw before functions words are
never explicitly passed any arguments
again the flow is
data data data word it's going to do
something in that data data data word
data word
um and when gershwin meets a word it
just invokes it there's no specific
call this word with these arguments it
uses the stack
as we said an implicit stack maintained
by the language
as focus says this is totally insane
right i mean like you can't keep more
than three things
in a stack in your head at one time you
really can't um
maybe you can i can't but he argues
that um if done correctly that you can
achieve levels of sustainedness and
elegance that are stunning
and uh i will you know code examples and
things like the factor programming
language are
a great testament to that this is
accomplished by
vigorous this is his words vigorous
factoring of words
and so before that factoring words is
not really refactoring it's just
factoring oh i want to take this part of
my code i can just copy and paste
define a new word put the name right
there and it just works because again
it's just the data flow
um when you have a lot of stack
manipulation going on like you have
three things top of the stack and you
want to do something to the third one
you got to move it
duplicate it does it consume it you that
is a signal to you the programmer that
you're
you're
getting in the weeds and there are other
ways to to frame it better
so i want to talk about factor at this
point to kind of introduce the real
niceties of gershwin's concatenate of
api because it's from factor
factors in continental language and this
just summarizes what a
uh that cypress language is a factor is
a series of words
functions that manipulate a stack of
references to dynamically type values
works for closure we're dynamically
typed all right so real quick
primer um on stack manipulation and
you know this has a data stack one two
three three is on the top of the stack
then two then one if i drop the topmost
item
i drop that three i now have one two
swap
and swap the two out on top of the stack
two and one i can duplicate the topmost
item dupe okay this is again
super quick primer on basic stock
manipulation
i can rotate things if i start with one
two three again on the stack and i
rotate them i get the
third item put to the front i can
hop in there and remove the second item
so we had
one three two i nipped three it's gone
now i have one two
i can over items i can take in this case
the 2 1
becomes 2 1 2. i took the 2 and
duplicated it put on the top
and then finally pick and this has i
have three items here 1 2 3 and i
get the third and i duplicate another
front so this kind of defines
most of the primitive stack manipulation
functions one needs
to refinagle the stack to perform you
know basic
basic functions um but as focus said if
you have a lot of this in your code
you can't reason about that right you
write like dupes flip flop twit
dupe you know come back two months later
you have no idea why you were swapping
right there and duping right there
um so you need better ways for most
situations to
frame what you the intent of the stack
manipulation
and just like enclosure there are ways
to deal with functions in a higher order
fashion
factor provides a higher order sort of
stack manipulation operators called data
flow combinators
and this is where the really interesting
stuff comes in because now we're not
worrying about like
swap doop doop dip nip it's i have
code i want to run i have a stack in
this state it needs to be in this state
afterwards how can i reason about in
kind of an equational way
what the stack looks like now and what i
want it to be so
factor defines four basic data flow
combinators they are preserving cleave
spread and apply
preserving is kind of the outlier it
temporarily hides values on the stack
while you do other things and the other
three are ways of taking one or more
quotations and one or more pieces of
data
and doing things with them in concert so
cleave takes multiple quotations applies
to a single value
spread multiple quotations to multiple
values pairwise
they have the same number and apply
takes a single quotation and
gives it multiple values so let's look
at these examples and see what they
might look like you know
simple math so we can kind of reason
about the stack in our heads maybe
maybe preserving combinators if i put
four and five on the stack
and i have a quotation that times the
top thing by two dip is going to take
the five off of the stack invoke that
two times quotation which gives us eight
and it's going to put five back on the
stack the first item so dip takes the
second item off invokes the quotation
puts it back on
this is a preserving combinator
preserved the five the
other preserving combinator is keep
which instead of taking that five off
keeps it there
invokes quotation and puts it back on so
here we had four and five again
we invoked two times give us ten and we
put the original value of five back on
the stack
so the two preserving combinators of
defining gershwin
from the factory api
cleave combinators notice there's no
dupes no keeps no overs
so i have two quotations and a single
piece of data and i want to invoke them
and put those values back on the stack i
put two on the stack i have two
quotations one for times two one for
times three
the the resulting stack is four and six
two times two is four three times two is
six
tri is also a cleave combinator it takes
three quotations
and so have 2 times 2 2 times 3 2 times
4 gives us those values in the stack
all these combinators also have their
extra arity equivalents where
you either change the number of
arguments to the quotation or the number
of quotations being used
so i i refer you to versions
implementation for those
spread combinators i have
n number of pieces of data i have number
of quotations i want to do things for
those things
pairwise so 2 times 2 3 times 3 gives me
4 and 9.
imagine what you'd have to do if you
wanted to manually manipulate the stack
to put those guys in place in both
quotations put them back
um all right and then try just like the
previous slide
takes three and does it with three
things okay
spread combinators apply combinators
finally
i have a single quotation and i want to
uh
give it multiple items up the stack by
default two so times two for two times
two for three gives us four and six
and try so all these mirror factors
names for these data flow combinators
except where they
obviously conflict with closure naming
convention you can't have special
symbols of the front so but the special
symbols at the back of the word so
um if you're referring to factor and
gershwin and parallel you kind of look
at these
in in parallel they should be
functionally equivalent
all right so we've given a preview of
some small mini examples
um when would you use gershwin as i said
what's wrong with closure i
i really enjoy closure i hack on it all
day when might you use gershwin what are
the use cases
this is a tweet recently by chris ford
he's talking about when he's designing
you know systems um
oftentimes there are rises two ways of
kind of working through your
building extra closure language if you
will building out your use of closure
a lot of times things work great if you
just do regular functional composition
as you would in most functional
languages
but closure also has these arrow macros
that allow you to thread these thread
macros that allow you to
thread forms through several expressions
um
and you know they have different uh
different characteristics
um let's look at a couple of examples
and see what he's talking about
so i have some data it's a vector of map
entries and if i wanted to get
the value for the lang key of the first
con content of the first item in that
vector this is one way to accomplish
that i can compose
these functions i compose first and then
content and then first and then lang
and i can pass data in as an argument
i'll get closure now wait a minute
we said stack based languages were in
reverse but i had to read that
from right to left to reason about and
what order the functions will be applied
to the data so
often times it it feels right and it
works better enclosure to
thread things through because it starts
to read more like we would kind of
reason
talk about it out loud i can thread data
and pass it to
second and then pass the return value of
that to the content function
to first into lang and get uh
gershwin second item in the list first
uh sub item so this is a way of kind of
in a more natural order to say given a
piece of data
thread it through these functions and
give me something at the end
that is what gershwin does that's that
is what concatenative languages do they
are like the threading macro
on steroids that's just the default
behavior you put data in place
you invoke words and it's threaded
through
so this is so and so in one grocery use
case is when you have arrows in your
code
and uh you're right you're writing
things that make sense in kind of a
that order um grisham is often effective
all right
all right so we've worked through
phonetics pronunciation the syntax of
the language worked through the
the meat and potatoes the words and
phrases functions
what's that last level for language
mastery um
you know and i'm gonna just glob all of
language learning into sentences and
paragraphs at this point
um well it's true right so when you when
you're graded as a language learner
um when you get past words you get into
sentences and you you can speak
sentences you can survive on the street
you go to that kiosk you ask that woman
for like that
pieroski and you can transact
right but you really can't survive in a
college seminar
um so to be fluent in a language really
have to get to the paragraph level of
discourse you have to be able to talk
about a beginning a middle and an end
you have to have transitions what's the
program equivalent of that it's what we
do every day it's building
actual applications the high level
modular components we put together to
build
real systems
what does closure provide for that
modularity first of all provides name
spaces
um every language needs to provide
namespaces
javascript um if there's no other reason
i use clojurescript
in the ui it's to have namespaces for my
for my client side code
all kinds of things in closure for
building out the larger components the
architectural components for
applications
to include things like how does it
handle dispatch multiple things there's
multi-methods which is arbitrary
dispatch protocols
you have access to java interfaces when
you need them how do we
show data flow in the application we
just saw examples of functional
composition
the threading macros and closure says
you can use state we're going to make it
scarce right it's a functional language
global mutable state should be at a
minimum and the goal should be
functional purity where possible
so if we take these three categories
that i've arbitrarily put for
language construction and we consider
them kind of
where they sit right there's the micro
level concerns that we are all as
language geeks super interested in like
how did you really implement those
closures
um you know is it is it telco all the
lower level functions
um and then the higher level you know
macro level concerns
at the macro level it's how do we build
the programs right how do we architect
the things we're building every day
at the micro level and this is the
important part and this is why
i think gershwin using closure as its
extension language
is the best choice because this is how
you trust your program right this is the
foundation on which
you reason about your code you know when
things change when they don't you know
how threads work you know how time works
um so what is you know what is closure's
micro level
set of you know guarantees and uh it has
these opinions and they're
they're highly effective right it's a
functional language it is a lisp
um but a list that doesn't allow you to
just arbitrarily add crazy syntax like i
did
um for with reader macros um it has
you know well-known and understood
concepts for these separate things which
are identity state value and time
and lastly it's a hosted language which
means that you having spent
you know 10 years on the jvm can move
from java to closure and have
all of the hosted part of closures
runtime semantics already kind of
understood because it's hosted language
either on the jvm
the clr or javascript so this provides
a foundation for a language
implementation that
is well understood while defined and
easy to reason about
okay we're going to get the inflammatory
quotes now again michael focus
a language that doesn't affect let you
affect the way it thinks
is not worth growing right this is this
is the argument for closure as an
extension language and gershwin as an
experiment and extending that language
um all these permutations of this
quotation are from
um or from allen pearl as we get there
um so what are extensions to closure
that already exist
right and what do we mean by extension
right it's a core async one of the
things that was mentioned about core
async
uh is and rich mentioned it during uh
the introductory podcast
um it can be implemented as a library
enclosure
right and part of the hazard of the fact
that it's a lisp and that the state
machine that powers
core async can be implemented behind a
macro um
and that allows us to extend closure of
the language with
the you know quote with a an
asynchronous api that would otherwise
have to be kind of
built in from the ground up other things
like corelogic which we've seen
in other you know other conferences um
having all of mini cameron which is a
a logic based lisp system enclosure and
you can stop doing
functional closure and start doing logic
closure and get back into functional
closure so that for parts of your
application that
were better expressed as a logic run
with logic semantics can be inserted
um things like core typed which ambrose
has been doing and then things like the
atomic you know
querying languages like the data logging
castle i can finally i'll put gershwin
at the bottom here
as another way of extending closure i
did the most damage by actually hacking
on the compiler
but these are all extensions to closure
that are possible due to
those micro level concerns that closure
has and guarantees
so this is the origin of all those
quotes a language doesn't affect the way
you think about programming is not worth
knowing
and then the most inflammatory version
michael focus has come up with so far if
your programming language is in the tool
for thought then you're
the tool uh
again you know having a language like
closure to extend and being able to say
on a bolt-on concatenative semantics to
this but still have all of closure
beneath it is a powerful thing
and it can it's telling a story so when
gershwin
lots of arrows in your code maybe that's
one good one i've used it to build a
very simple system shell
so i can like boot up a gershwin shell
and often times when writing shell we
write commands that are both applicative
you know
grep and its arguments and other times
that are a concatenative grep
and some things pipe to another function
and that pipe is
the threading macro that pipe is the
concatenative approach of flowing data
through multiple expressions
if it fits your brain or the problem
right this is again that why why
gershwin
certain things that fits very well if
you look in the factor
set of libraries or some excellent gui
programs that look very natural in a
concatenative style
for constructing gui's and then there's
a couple of projects on the gershwin
github
so anyway if you want to explore more i
highly recommend the bottom two links
to start closure's implementation and
factor
as the stack language of choice and then
this is gershwin's website and
the github repo thank you